[Music]
toos Godzilla minus 1 is a movie that
has rocked the very core of Hollywood a
mega movie that was made for only less
than $15 million and yet having near
perfect CGI and great acting as well as
storytelling minus one just puts Disney
to shame with their $200 million movies
which begs the question where does all
the money go to this Godzilla is making
headlights and breaking records all over
and with just less than 10% of a budget
of a Marvel flake and it was a sight to
see get your tickets and scadal right to
the nearest theater but sadly most of
the worlds will still have to wait for
this masterpiece anyway here in this
video we will discuss the origins of
this Godzilla the size of the premutated
version its design and all about it so
let's get to it so firstly Godzilla in
all his different movies and
incarnations has had different origin
Stories the very first one was created
by radiation from a nuclear test
conducted by the US in the Pacific Ocean
the Hy Godzilla was originally a
dinosaur called godzillasaurus that
survived in an island on the Pacific and
was mutated by The Castle Bravo test in
1954 the 1998 triar Godzilla also had a
similar origin story but was an iguana
egg that was irradiated and hence the
baby's DNA mutated to form in to this
Colossal Kaiju gmk was a Reincarnation
of the dead of World War II Shin
Godzilla was a hyper evolving creature
that came out of nuclear wte singular
Point Godzilla is a transdimensional
monster Godzilla Earth is the result of
ultimate evolution and the monsterverse
Godzilla is an ancient Titan that came
from the hollow Earth so where did
Godzilla minus one come from in the
movie This Godzilla was seen first in
the opening scenes as a gigantic
dinosaur-like monster called Gojira by
the locals of Odo island in the Pacific
for those who don't know or who are new
to the Godzilla lore Odo island is a
fictional island separate from the
Japanese chain of islands and situated
somewhere in the Pacific this place is
most notable for being a part of the
first Godzilla movie ever as the place
where the first sighting of the OG
Godzilla was reported in the movie
anyway in minus one Gojira there was
known to the natives as a sea monster
that at times appears and brings up deep
sea fish to the island whether or not it
lived in harmony with the natives is
unknown but judging by its fierceness
and aggressiveness towards humans it
probably was a very territorial animal
and it might have harbored hatred
towards humans due to World War to
anyway this dinosaur likee creature is
of course a godzillasaurus which took
inspiration from the Jay origin story
and mix it with the showa location since
it was lagus Island not Odo Island that
was the hope of the godzillasaurus in
the 1984 movie so the first interaction
in minus one was in 1945 between the
Japanese soldiers and this dinosaur like
Godzilla which was not yet mutated and
this interaction resulted in most of the
Japanese being killed yet they were not
eaten or consumed meaning it was acting
territorially or out of pure hatred the
only survivors of this ordeal was
tachibana and shikishima who carried
something known as survivors guilt after
seeing their comrades dead while they
still lived on anyway this theme would
carry the movie forward and set the tone
of the story arc as well a year later
after the second world war ended with
the atomic bombings of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki the US and USSR went to the
beginnings of a state of cold war
between them the US would start to test
nukes in the Pacific in the Bikini atal
these were named Operation Crossroads
and were a pair of nuclear weapon tests
conducted by the US in mid 1946 they
were the first nuclear weapons tests
since Trinity and the first detonations
of a nuclear device after Nagasaki the
purpose of these tests was to
investigate the effect of nuclear
weapons on warships but unfortunately in
the movie these were also the Genesis of
Godzilla the radiation from these tests
mutated the godzillasaurus on Odo Island
which is situated very near the test
sides and from this the godzillasaurus
became Godzilla which grew way bigger
and develop strange new abilities like
shooting an atomic breath and having a
rapid regeneration Factor as well as
developing a Sinister and evil intention
towards Humanity probably the same
hatred it had as a dinosaur but then
magnified 10 times by the radiation now
let's take a look at its design and its
size this godzillasaurus has a very
similar appearance to the mutated
Godzilla of the movie it did not have
that stock difference as godzillasaurus
and Godzilla of the H era did these two
were very different looking creatures
this Dino from the minus one movie was
unmistakenly the same as the Kaiju that
would later terrorize Japan it was 15 M
or 50 ft tall and was around 30 m or 100
ft long from head to tail it had a
dorsal plates which although were
noticeable weren't really as large as
the final product nor were they as big
in ratio to its body size as the ones in
the mutated Godzilla it had a larger
head relative to the body size a longer
arms ratio and Slimmer legs it has sort
of a Crouch posture a bit bent or slouch
in the middle and looked to be somewhat
of a spiky and a gigantic Jurassic world
T-Rex it was also very agile very very
fast and Hyper aggressive after mutation
it became a 50.1 m or 165 ft tall Kaiju
which stood more upright and has nuclear
Powers as well as the body features
becoming thicker especially the legs so
are there more of them out there well if
this was just a Cryptid that lived
unknown to the world in a remote island
and in the ocean there is bound to be an
actual population of these creatures it
wasn't stated to be an immortal creature
only getting regeneration abilities from
the nuclear radiation later on so
logically a godzillasaurus would just be
one specimen of a species an individual
who needs to procreate and live out a
life cycle anyway if that piece of Flesh
doesn't grow into another Godzilla in
the end of the movie then if we get a
sequel it'll be like Godzilla rates
again another individual was transformed
by the nukes now if you like this video
then watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for more Monster
videos till the next time take care fam